a New Mexico judge allowed a 19 year old
to attend college as she awaits trial
for killing her newborn baby in response
a petition is surfaced online trying to
ban the woman from the University Alexi
trevizo is charged with first-degree
murder child abuse and tampering with
evidence in connection to the incident
in late January Treviso went to the
hospital with back pain allegedly not
knowing that she was pregnant and 24
hours later hospital staff found the
body of treviso's son in a bathroom
trash can an autopsy ruled the baby's
death a homicide apparently dying from a
lack of oxygen but defense attorneys
argue that treviso's son was in fact
stillborn and the baby's death was
actually a result of Hospital
malpractice last week trevisa's defense
team argued that her bail condition
should be modified so she can attend
fall classes at New Mexico State
University jervisa was previously banned
from contacting her boyfriend who
attends the same University but the
presiding judge sided with the defense
since the relationship was wasn't deemed
violent as of Monday more than 13
thousand people have signed a petition
on change.org asking the university to
reconsider treviso's admission according
to the description the petition's goal
is to quote protect vulnerable
individuals and ensure their safety
Brian you think this condition is going
to work that she'll be not allowed back
in I don't think so so a little over 13
000 people I looked it up the state of
the New Mexico State University and it
has just a little over 11 000 people so
clearly this is not just the student
body if it is even the student body it
could be people from outside the school
I think this might be dealt with more
internally but also I'm still stuck on
the protecting vulnerable individuals
who's the vulnerable individual you're
talking about are you talking about the
fact that She's accused of a crime and
now you don't want anyone around her
because of that well we let people
accuse of crimes walk among us all the
time even murderers the other thing too
is if it's specific to the crime that
she committed or She's accused of
committing what do you think she's going
to do force herself on men get pregnant
and then get rid of that child again
it's it's it's absurd to kind of make
sure it's the idea of an accused murder
I mean like without looking at the facts
that's what they're going to say but if
it's an accused murderer then it would
make more sense based on how they
murdered did they stab someone shoot
someone or take advantage of a child
because that the judge already decided
she's not a danger to others that's why
she's released on bail I guess the I
mean Brian's making a good point I
always thought you were innocent until
proven guilty but then again the people
who sign this position do they have a
right they have a First Amendment right
to put this out there could they face
any legal consequences for doing this
and affecting her career yeah I mean
they have a First Amendment right Jesse
but I think here what they are doing is
jumping the gun I mean you are innocent
until you are proven guilty and here she
was let out the judge did allow her to
go to the college and frankly I think
they could face intentional infliction
of emotional distress frankly because I
mean travisa would sue them for that
that is correct because she's trying to
live her life she's been allowed out and
now you have these people who are are
basically claiming that she's going to
murder again and there's no proof of
that and so for that cause of action as
you all know you have to have outrageous
behavior now whether or not it's
outrageous to have this petition
actually I think it is sort of
outrageous to have this petition against
this young lady like Brian said what is
she going to do so you know if that
outrageous behavior was intentional it
caused severe emotional distress I think
Teresa could win a claim against them
but doesn't it matter if she's found
guilty if she's found guilty of murder
then wouldn't that claim not really work
because the student body would be like
okay yeah we were right she's a murderer
I think it goes back to the
circumstances in which she murdered
right it doesn't make like are you
worried that she's gonna murder you I'm
not on the campus I'm not I'm not gonna
have a child with her but other than
that I don't think there's an issue of
fear of murder yeah all right when we
come back a popular Wing joint is the
focus of a lawsuit for their
controversial layoffs during the
pandemic allegations from One Federal
agency against a Hooters restaurant in
North Carolina that's next
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody a government
agency is suing a North Carolina Hooters
restaurant over allegations of racial
discrimination against employees the
suit was announced Thursday by the U.S
equal employment opportunity commission
during the 2020 covet pandemic the
Hooters Restaurant in Greensboro North
Carolina had to lay off more than 40
employees known to the chain as Hooters
girls employees were able to return to
work the lawsuit alleges a majority of
the women called back were white or
light-skinned the federal agency broke
down the accusation through data you see
prior to the covid-19 layoffs 51 percent
of the Hooters girls at the Greensboro
location were black or dark-skinned
women but after May of 2020 that number
reportedly went down to just 8 percent
the suit also claims that in addition to
receiving slower shifts dark-skinned
Hooters girls quote experienced racial
hostility while employed at the
restaurant and observed preferential
treatment of white employees the
commission is asking for an injunction
against the chain and back pay for the
former Hooters girls in addition to
compensatory and punitive damages Terry
you've tried employment discriminations
cases before what do you think of this
one I think it's a good one you know in
employment discrimination you have
direct actions you have indirect actions
the direct action is when there is a
direct adverse action against an
individual the indirect is when you have
a pattern of practice in either case
you're going to have to show that there
was some sort of race discrimination I
think here what Hooters is going to have
to do if they're going to defend this
case is to say look there was no
discrimination all of our decisions were
based on business reasons that had
nothing to do with the color of their
skin I think that's going to be very
difficult in this case because it does
look as though they have the numbers
behind them to bring this lawsuit that's
the part Brian if the numbers are behind
them isn't this like a simple case I
think he has to know back to Terry what
you're saying she's got to go back and
say so you rehired 13 people and one of
them over darker skin or darker
complexion why did you hire that one and
not everyone else to maintain those
numbers but I think even just this case
is just a small bit of sand on the beach
because Hooters has a history of being
ensue with weight bias they've actually
had a case like this back in 2015 of
racial bias where a dark-skinned woman
said oh you're only hiring the blondes
and I'm not allowed to come in and also
interestingly enough they've also had
gender discrimination on at least two
occasions where men try to get on onto
the employment and they were not allowed
to so kudor seems to be almost be
unnoticed as to these types of
discrimination even though they're
individual chains operating throughout
the country and I think that history may
actually help the plaintiffs in this
case along with the numbers so if that's
true and Hooters were to lose this take
it all the way to trial and lose it what
are the damages here and could they be
worse if as Brian said since they have a
you know a history of it oh the damages
could be in the millions and not only
that they could get an injunction
against them they're going to have to
change their policies and it will be a
lot of money There's No Limit right now
you can get compensatory damages you can
get punitive damages and that's a lot of
money all right serious case you should
apply
Ryan Terry good to see you bro everyone
thanks for joining us here along crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
[Music]
thank you